.
WH D NO
>> Repr: THIN W FROM
SENATORCHWEETING
ABOUT CHARGESOFFICERS.NOWELED
AT WE O VIDEOHAEDKI JAY
EX MASE ANDTOU
AIDI ABETTIN
SE MURDER.
NOWAS THOSE COU
THAT
CE PREVIOUSLY THIRD-DEGREE
MURD, WE'RE TKIDEREK CHAUVIN, CG
BEEN ELEVADDEGREE
MURD.ORDINGE FROM THE
AT OF BROOKE, THA W
HIT
IN GEORGE
FL H C
AUTHORIT HAMNKMU
AN ELL LIE, LITD.LO DI KILLED,
WEGO
AND H WE AREOW AWEREMEDIATELY F
THIS COUNTRY WERE CALLING F
TAV
LEAD OFFER CUVCHREE MUTHE OTHER
THREE OFFICERS AS  IT
TO
ABETTING SECOND-DEGREE MURDER, E
UNDERSCOREOWHISIS.
>> BOKIVEO THEYADE IS UNDERN IT
AND PEOERIERIN
ABETNG CRG A WEENDS GOOD WORKAT.
NCAUSEY E  THISCO
WEBOUT JUSTI
EL OVER A WEEK TSWIFT, BUT WHATT
PR OARGED. IS
, A, UNDER THE CONSTI ENTITLED
VEEA FUTUR
PART OF THE NTRYING TTH
COULD NE
OTHE TO COOPERATE ALTINGAINST P.
WEOFE'.THLL THE CAMERA BACK AND
THIS OUTF JUS FOR
A F CELL PHOIDEO. T OFOWYRGE THE
HAVE BEEN ACROSS WHO -
THAT THEENOS TTATES.
ME. THERE ACROSS T S THERE WERE
BYSTANDER.
TO SOME THIS ISST VAL BODY
R POLICE AND A
THE POWER
OF T CELLHEITANDBI O SEE WHAT HA
PO PLACE.HI BIG TAKEAWAY, IS THP
ELLIOTT A ELIE HO SND
BY.E THEOIACP, DEREK JOHNSON JO,
YOU'VE HEA USCU
NEWS, ALL FOUR OF THEIC
CHD,
AR ELEVATE REE MURDER.
YOUR AC TIS G D
T, O WHO
D TN MAN, MURD DAYLIGHT BYS. IN
PLEA W P FORS SOUSE T COMMUNITY
Y WHOEFUSED TO THAATEY ONE  THAD
HIS RALWE OBVIOUSTO E VIEWEDDE
PLED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY COULD NOT
BRINGSELF TGETAT THE STATE ATTOA
JUIC SERVED
NOW.
>> DEREK SE, SIR, A VOR, BY.FOP
IS WITH THEMYES
FLOORS.
IRSTST TO SAY SORRYNHIS., BENJA.
MYBEENEWE WANT JUSTICE.
>> ANDE.
ST, LET ME AAND
THERE.
VERIONAL.
IT IS EMOTIONALOR
ANDS
O
I TO HAVETN K AND IDETAILEC
PUT THERE ANYEMIO
THROUGH BUT IT WASRIFIC DEATH T
I'TDE STROUBLED ANDEEN THROH.T
PERSON DOWS NECK.
HE IS BEING CHANS MURD SORRYOEP
SE MUR
R.EY HAVE NOWS  FROOSH
CAMPBELL, CHARGED THEER
THERS MET YOU ARENDHI
THAT HAV OUT F.
HE F ALL
ATEIS HORF
R.
TH CHARGESINRS, WE  SHOULD BE
DIING CHARGEE
OR IT SEL MURDER
OF SOMEE.USEKNF
RRCIIOAE H FOR RIO IT MINOR ATH.
WE'RLIHEY HAVE BEUP SOND-DEGR
MURDER.BUT THENEY GENERAL HASTH
STGO AT-DEGREE MURDER NVONILL IT
RECORD
RNG CIVIL
MOVED EXPEDIT INESTING
THEIC WERGE FLOYDMORROWMIOT
>> RKTHATHEIT
E OU HEAR
AOUE YI'LL ASK IT
DID YOU SEE WHEN YOU TT VIIN, W.
D DEAE HE AS TTHE KNEE NK
CAN'T BREATHE. CD MOMMANHIRATHI
IRST COME IN THIS
FOR HIM TO CALL FOR HER
REBOOUTWARDXPRESS OMPTT
AND NTWAS
SO THE MINNESOTA GOVR
RIGH TOS
VI BY THE MINNEAPOLIS  FORROBABT